.
IT IS MONDAY, SEPTEMBER 20th.
I'M JOHN BERMAN WITH BRIANNA
KEILAR.
THIS MORNING A MAJOR DEVELOPMENT
IN THE CASE OF 22-YEAR-OLD GABBY
PETITO MISSING FOR WEEK.
THIS WAS A POST FROM HER FATHER
OVERNIGHT, SHE TOUCHED THE
WORLD.
HUMAN REMAINS BELIEVED TO BE
PETITO HAD BEEN DISCOVERED IN
NORTHERN WYOMING.
AN AUTOPSY IS SCHEDULED FOR
TOMORROW.
THE FBI SAYS CAUSE OF DEATH HAS
NOT YET BEEN DETERMINED.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENTS FOUND THE
BODY AFTER SEARCHING CAMP SITES
ON THE BORDER OF GRAND TETON
NATIONAL PARK
>> THEY ARE NOW SEARCHING FOR
PETITO'S FIANCEE BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
THE COUNTRY LEFT ON A CROSS
COUNTRY ROAD TRIP IN JUNE.
BUT LAUNDRIE RETURNED HOME
WITHOUT PA TEE TA.
PETITO.
>> Reporter: BRIANBRIANNA, THIS
WHERE THE COUPLE LIVED WITH
BRIAN'S FAMILY.
NORTH PORBGT POLICE ARE SAYING
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE FBI IN SEARCH OF ANSWERS KEY
TO THIS INVESTIGATION RIGHT NOW
WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENED AND WHERE
IS BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
FBI INVESTIGATORS ANNOUNCING A
BODY WAS DISCOVERED IN THE GRAND
TETON NATIONAL FOREST SAYING IT
COULD BE MISSING 22-YEAR-OLD
GABBY PETITO.
>> HUMAN REMAINS WERE DISCOVERED
CONSISTENT WITH THE DESCRIPTION
OF GABRIELLE GABBY PETITO.
FULL FORENSIC IDENTIFICATION HAS
NOT YET BEEN COMPLETED TO
CONFIRM 100% THAT WE FOUND
GABBY, BUT HER FAMILY HAS BEEN
NOTIFIED OF THIS DISCOVERY.
>> Reporter: PA TEE TA,
DISAPPEARING ON A CROSS COUNTRY
DRIVE WITH HER FIANCEE LAST
MONTH.
THE COUPLE DOCUMENTING THEIR
JOURNEY ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> GOOD MORNING.
IT IS REALLY NICE AND SUNNY
TODAY.
>> Reporter: POSTING PHOTOS AND
VIDEOS OF THEIR TRIP, START
ANYTHING JULY, WITH PLANS TO END
IN OREGON IN OCTOBER.
BUT PETITO'S FAMILY SAYS THEY
LOST CONTACT WITH HER AT THE END
OF AUGUST.
ABOUT TWO WEEKS AFTER POLICE IN
MOAB, UTAH, RESPONDED TO A
REPORT OF DISORDERLY CONDUCT
BETWEEN THE COUPLE.
AFTER THE INCIDENT, POLICE
FILING A REPORT SAYING PETITO
AND LAUNDRIE ENGAGED IN SOME
SORT OF ALTERCATION.
HE RETURNED TO FLORIDA WITHOUT
HER SEPTEMBER 1st.
TEN DAYS LATER, SHE WAS REPORTED
MISSING.
>> MY GUT TELLS ME SOMETHING BAD
HAPPENED.
AND I'M NEVER, NEVER GOING TO BE
ABLE TO HOLD MY BABY GIRL AGAIN.
>> Reporter: NOW THE SEARCH DOES
ON FOR LAUNDRIE, WHO HAS
DISAPPEARED.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR THE
23-YEAR-OLD AT THIS NATURE
RESERVE.
THEY SAID FRIDAY THEY LAST SAW
HIM ON TUESDAY.
.
>> HIS FAMILY SAYS THAT THIS IS
A PLACE THAT HE FREQUENTS.
THEY BELIEVE THIS IS WHERE HE
CAME.
>> Reporter: PETITO'S FAMILY
WITH THEIR GRIEF OVERNIGHT.
HE WROTE, SHE TOUCHED THE WORLD.
THE FBI IS STILL LOOKING FOR ANY
LEADS ABOUT HER DISAPPEARANCE
>> THIS IS AN ACTIVE AND ONGOING
INVESTIGATION.
WE ASK EVERYONE MAINTAIN
DISTANCE FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL AND EQUIPMENT.
VEHICLES AND RELATED ACTIVITY,
FOR THEIR OWN SAFETY, AS WELL AS
TO PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
WORK AND RESPECT PRIVACY FOR
GABBY'S FAMILY.
>> Reporter: AND, BRIANNA, I CAN
TELL YOU LAST NIGHT QUITE A BIT
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE
HERE.
THERE IS A SENSE OF FRUSTRATION
AMONG INVESTIGATORS, QUITE
FRANKLY, AMONG THE COMMUNITY,
WANTING MORE COOPERATION, MORE
HELP FROM BRIAN LAUNDRIE'S
FAMILY.